thank you
well hey everybody what's going on well
that is too dark well yeah see I told
you that it looked okay but you didn't
believe me
that's what happens when you don't
listen to Jenny yeah right see that's
probably better yeah I know what's going
on it's Monday and uh you know we're
doing a movie review I'm having a drink
because yeah it's been a day just gonna
tell you that right now
I picked this one out Jenny never saw
this one I had heard of it but I never
got around to seeing it and it's like
this one's really fun and I thought it
was like it's uh kind of underrated you
don't really hear a lot of people
talking about it yeah this is uh this is
like the American version of zatoichi
it's it's almost a retelling of a
Japanese well it is actually a loose
remake of one particular zatoichi movie
which is zatuichi challenged yeah which
I think came out in the late 60s I
haven't seen that was the 17th movie
also known as katsushin a great singer
uh interesting character
um and a good actor and he basically
invented
zotuichi he made that character uh by
himself as he just went along and a
bunch of [__] cool [__] happened
started off in the black and white era
and then it went into the color era
um I think the last zatsuichi movie came
out in 1989 which was the same year that
this movie came out yeah yeah I've
actually seen that one I think it's if
it's the same one we're talking about
that was the one that had it was Chantal
katsu right yeah okay yeah because there
was another one that came out after that
another guy it was another guy yeah it
wasn't that good though
what's funny is that that last the last
is out to each he had was the Japanese
guys with blonde hair and blue eyes and
I was like wow they're now they're
ripping off Blind Fury
yeah maybe well yeah well like I said I
don't know about that because that came
out the last satuichi movie came out the
same year as this came out and what
ended up happening was that
Tim Matheson who's actually better known
as an actor like he's been in a ton of
[__] but I know him from um uh Sometimes
they come back the Stephen King
adaptation like he was in that and he
was the producer on this and the reason
why he wanted to be the producer on this
was because he was a really big fan of
the zatoichi movies and wanted to do
like an American version of it although
I will say that this is more comedic I
think although the zatoichi movies had
humor in them too yeah but this one is
kind of more like it's listed as an
action comedy
but it still has
I don't know if I'd go so far as say
it's like an out and out comedy because
it has just had a comedic relief in it
it does yeah it does have like a lot of
comedy in it but I don't know if I would
straight up call it again yeah it's not
to eat you had that too yeah so it was
similar real similar good Rucker Howard
we're talking about Rucker Howard Rucker
Howard yeah yeah did I say that you said
Howard no I didn't yeah you did I did
okay yeah
I know what you said grammar Nazi Rucker
Howard he did it again
there's no d on there man I didn't say a
d it's a Dutch name it sounded like you
didn't know
but yeah so I'd look I love Rucker
Howard and it's just that I hadn't I
think the thing about it is this came
out in the theater got a theatrical
release although I think it only got a
theatrical release like later I think it
only came out like in theaters in 1990
yeah and it got like pretty okay reviews
like Cisco neighbor really liked it and
a lot of critics liked it and stuff like
that but I don't think it made a [__]
ton of money but then it was on cable
all the time and it was like a pretty
popular like VHS rental so I'm guessing
it did okay and it just got you know
what I saw I was like looking at other
reviews of it and it just got um I don't
know if it was it's like fairly recently
it got a um like a Blu-ray re-release
and they put it like in a VHS like slip
cover thing that looks like a VHS it's
cool looking they didn't I don't think
there's like super special features on
it or nothing like that unfortunately
but it looks really nice though like the
one version we saw was on Amazon Prime
and we just kind of like were scrolling
through the movies and Tom's like oh I
kind of now you had you seen it you I
didn't you say you'd seen it yeah yeah I
saw it I saw it on VHS yeah because I
thought it was like it was on cable all
the time like back in the early 90s I
feel like oh we rented it yeah I think
we I think we saw it several times
yeah I think it was a pretty popular
rental I don't think I would have ever
rented it though because I was like too
busy running horror movies
but yeah so this was actually directed
by kind of like a big name guy Philip
noyce he also did um Dead Calm which is
a great movie he did sliver he did um
The Bone Collector he did some of the
Jack Ryan movies with Harrison Ford like
he did Patriot Games um clear and
present danger so
um so this was kind of like right in his
wheelhouse and like I said this was uh
very specifically based on zatoichi
challenged yeah although it's kind of
you know obviously it's like a
modernization because it said in the
modern day or It said In 1989 whereas
the zatoichi movies are set in what the
yeah I guess 1700s I think 1600s maybe
um
for those who don't know who zatoichi is
he's it's just a just a a large like you
said 17 movies right no there's more
than that more than that 20 something
there's 20 something movies yeah and
they're Japanese
sword movies
about a Yakuza Swordsman
blind yeah
and he's a masseur he and a beggar he
just walks from one
place to the next kind of like Kane out
of kung fu
and when he gets there he gets involved
with like
girls that got sold into prostitution
he's got to figure out how to get him
out you know because their loser husband
[__] sold them into prostitution to
pay the farm debt type of deal so he's
got to deal with the damn brothel owners
and gangsters and uh crooked Samurai
just whatever
and he's kind of a
he's a Yakuza
which means Gambler really uh kind of
like a Wandering gambler
goes into gambling houses
kind of cheats in a certain way but they
try to cheat him a bunch of bunch of
cool scenes with that
he knows that because he's blind people
are going to try to take advantage of
him so he has all these scams to flip
that back around on them so he can
scam then
um
it's a good very unique series a record
a series of movies I recommend any of
them you don't have to see them in any
kind of order yeah they're all
Standalone they can all be Standard
Loans and a lot of them are kind of like
after you've seen a few of them they're
all kind of samey
but
they're very popular in Japan 60s and
70s and 80s
well this is a reboot of that yeah it's
a very similar story to what you would
have seen in the liquor movie except
said in the presence act now shataro
katsu who played
satoichi
he was quite a character he was he was a
partier but he also could do he had
sword fencing
training
and he accidentally killed a guy on a
set with a sword and that was a big
scandal in Japan it was a real sword
but the dude is his friend and it was
just but they accused him of being drunk
and
I don't think he was drunk but he was a
draker he also he liked cocaine and
evidently too
um but he could sing and he would
release albums
singing as zatoichi
and like the one of the best songs you
can go on YouTube you can listen to it
it's called darkness is my Ally
that he was in that particular song is
in 89 is really good and it's all in
Japanese
and um kind of like western music but
with like a western music you know the
instruments
not really you can see because you know
it was we had Cowboy we had Cowboy
westerns and [__] like that here over in
Japan it was Samurai movies that you
know I mean it was it's the same thing
yeah it's like the same genre pretty
much yeah it's just like slightly
filtered through different cultural lens
but uh yeah it's pretty much the same so
um
but he's a Yakuza and he's blind and
he's got a cane and inside that Blind
Man's cane is a blade a sword it's
straight
it's not curved like a samurai sword
and he's good and um real good he
doesn't need to see
well Rucker Howard plays a character
like that
he's a Vietnam veteran who gets
becomes uh uh M.I.A in Vietnam yeah and
some they look like um Mountain yards
which is kind of like you know um
um
Vietnamese tribal people looks like they
look like it was them that took him in
and rehabilitated him because he got
blinded by like a mortar actually yeah
and
um they had a swordmaster in there that
taught him how to use a sword
and he was over there for about 20 years
and he finally comes back to the United
States
and his name was evidently on the
Vietnam on that Vietnam memorial wall
they thought he was dead but he wasn't I
don't think he ever told him that he was
alive
yeah I guess he didn't well it seemed
like well he didn't seem to have like a
family or anything she went back looking
for his uh his best friend in the Army
it turned out that guy got
got involved with a bunch of gangsters
out of Reno they were like they they
were involved in a casino stuff and they
were making designer drugs and he had
become a chemist his buddy and uh in the
ensuing years and then um so he tries to
find him ends up at his house and while
he's there some gangsters come he finds
out that the that that guy had left his
wife and kid that he broke up and some
gangsters came up looking for him
and they killed a wife and he ends up
kind of inherited custody of the kid
he's trying to bring the kid back to his
father and the gangsters are all
involved there's all these showdowns and
[__] towards the ends it's pretty good
it's like it's like a South to each
movie I mean it's it's a star-studded
cast too because not only is Rucker
Howard in this he's like the main
character but also you have um the guy
who plays his army buddy like the guy
that's the chemist that gets roped into
like making these designer drugs for
these gangsters is Terry O'Quinn who
probably best known from lost but I
recognized him from the stepfather which
came out a couple years before this was
a great movie by the way I reviewed that
like a little while back it's like a
horror Thriller
um weirdly enough he's credited as
Terence O'Quinn in this even though I'm
pretty sure he's credited as Terry
O'Quinn in everything else that I've
seen him in but I think that was weird
um also one of the gangsters like the
main gangster is played by Randall Tex
Cobb who also played the um the scary
motorcycle guy in Raising Arizona so
there's that also the wife
of Terry o'quinn's character is played
by Meg Foster yeah we were very excited
when we saw her uh name in the credits
Tom met her at when we were at the
horror convention yeah she's a little
bitty thing I [__] just pulled her
into me [__] like that and like Jenny
took a picture of us yeah we still have
that somewhere she's still recognizable
she still looks like that
I said you want to have Drake I'm gonna
go get a drink she's like yeah no I
can't I gotta work yeah
yeah she did though for a second
because she had to go down there and do
autographs yeah yeah that's right yes
but yeah so yeah we just saw her walking
by like because we were there of like
signing books and stuff and
we just saw her walking by and I was
like Hey That's Mike Foster so uh so
yeah so we were excited because I love
her but it's like we were excited when
we saw her name in the credits spoiler
alert she is in literally one [__]
scene yeah one scene to kill her off
like in five I was I know it's like they
like Rucker Howard goes to the house
like thinking is everybody still lives
there like where was that at that was oh
it was in Florida that was in Miami yeah
they're in the South a lot of times yeah
and and then it's like a road trip kind
of thing yeah but so yeah I'm going
through [__] Alabama
yeah
that was a an experience I'd rather not
repeat it was back when that was back
when airplane trips were a lot more
expensive than they are now yeah I have
400 bucks you couldn't ride on a damn
airplane
you had to go on a bus but sometimes
it's like worth it because well I don't
know I hate to fly but now it's just
kind of like I don't I don't know which
is worse because flying an airplane now
is kind of Stucky too because it's not
as fun as it was no well I mean you know
damn security that and then it's just
like there's always like crap crabby ass
people and they try to cram as many
people on the plane as possible and yeah
they're screaming babies and [__] like
that which is I guess that's the same
true of like a bus but you know what I
mean yeah you get less crazy people on a
plane but I don't know if that's true
anymore though
yeah um Zach says man that pisses me off
they advertise a big and super toasted
actor like they're starring in a movie
and they're only in for five minutes
yeah well yeah it's like now in their
defense there's another one her name was
like toward the end of the credits and I
just like noticed I was like oh Meg
Foster's in this and then it's like so
when she turned up I'm like hey there
she is hey Meg and then um and she's in
one scene and then she gets [__]
blown away and I was like well buy a bag
that [__] is gorgeous in Masters of the
Universe
and He-Man I am in that movie in a long
time maybe we should review that one it
was like the evil queen in that man she
looks [__] great now here's the thing
about her eyes I've always wondered what
they do to her eyes to get him that yeah
because she's got freaky looking eyes
when I met her she did have blue eyes
they didn't look that intense I think
they colored they did something to him
well I don't know if it's that or if
it's just like the lighting that they
use or something or she put blue contact
some kind of crazy blue contacts over
her blue eyes maybe it's hard to say but
yeah because they are a person in person
they looked blue but they didn't stand
out that much right yeah because like
you see her in a movie in this one too
like you know her eyes are like
yeah they don't look like human really I
think they were contacts but that's kind
of her that's her thing that was like
her trademark her calling card so it's
like so yeah so don't get too excited
about her being in it because she's
great in it I'm not saying that but it's
she's in it for like maybe two or three
minutes and then she gets [__] shot
and also the kid that's in this I knew I
recognized him for something from
something
the kid that was in this uh the actor's
name is Brandon call he was on one of
those shitty do you remember on I don't
even remember what network this was
but back in the 80s and 90s they had
that um that string of sitcoms that was
called TGIF do you remember that
um and they had a show on there called
step by step and this kid was on it
because the whole time I'm like it's not
I know that's not Jonathan Taylor Thomas
but it's like one of those Jonathan
Taylor Thomas clones that came out
around that time because all his child
actors that kind of looked like that
like those sassy blonde boys with the
[__] you know what I mean so he looks
kind of like that and I have too much
attention to sassy blonde boys well I
didn't either but it's just like they
were just in the Zeitgeist and my sister
was a little bit younger she didn't
really watch that [__] either but it was
just always kind of on Zach did you pay
attention to them uh sassy blonde boys
back in the day
and not even no I I shouldn't use the
word sassy because that actually implies
a good thing I'm talking about like this
Eric because you know how the 90s
everything was like extreme and
everybody was just like smart asses like
that and it's just like I hate
Terminator too right like yeah for a
long like that like everybody had to be
like extreme and like badass and I was
just like you know what I mean so like I
hate the 90s like I said so um not all
of the 90s but I hated that about the
90s and it seemed like a lot of child
actors were like that and to an extent
the kid in this is kind of along those
same lines so honestly the kid in this I
really wanted to like punt him across
the [__] room you know what I'm
saying he's supposed to be like that
though like he's supposed to be shitty
um you know and he starts out but the
great thing about it is that it's like
after his mom gets shot
um
and uh and Nick which is Rucker Howard's
character's name the blind guy yeah I
was going like it must be Nick Fury yeah
I got Nick Nick Parker is his name but
yeah okay
but um but yeah so he takes the kid
because he promised the mom like before
she died she's like take care of my kid
even though I just met you you know what
I mean so it's that kind of thing so
he's gonna take the kid cross country at
first not telling him that his mom is
dead so I was like well that's a little
shitty because he wasn't like a little
little kid he was like 12. right about
that 11 12 11 or 12. so he's like a
tween
so the kid is like shitty at first like
he's always like trying to make fun of
the blind guy and it's like you know the
black guy slips and falls and he just
thinks it's hilarious it's like that
kind of so he's a real [__] but I do
like that Nick's character like doesn't
really
play like doesn't really [__] like he
doesn't get mad at him but he basically
fights back he yeah he basically just
doesn't let him get away with [__] like
to be honest so I thought that was kind
of good but it's like you know the kid
is just kind of like oh he's like why
are we going to see my dad my dad
doesn't want me and I'm like well I
don't blame him I wouldn't want you
either yeah
yeah I'd suck so I kept like hoping like
through the whole movie I was like maybe
he'll get hit by a bus but like he does
get better like as it goes on like he
actually does chill out but it's it does
have that
that late 80s early 90s
smart ass kid kind of Bart Simpson kind
of thing going on I blame Bart Simpson
for that I think that was the first one
that did that kind of [__] but he does
have that but it works out okay I think
Married with Children started all that
[__] oh maybe it did well you know not
really because those kids that at all
well those kids were older though yeah
but I'm just saying from that
series which is about they were trying
to say instead of all this Aussie
inheritance because this is it wouldn't
go the other direction like this is the
way families really are there which was
closer to the truth guys
I mean it's exaggerated for sure yeah
but and it was it was fun not that it
was fun but from there I noticed a bunch
of characters came off of that off of
that concept yeah
like I said
late 80s yeah like I said I think Bart
Simpson was a big Touchstone for that
too because he was like right around
that age and he was just like he's
getting kind of like a rip-off of
[__] Married With Children
thought that series well see I thought
The Simpsons started but well no I guess
it did nothing where did they start like
around the same time now I can't even
remember I was around when all that
started but well The Simpsons started on
the Tracy Allman show I thought like as
shorts I don't know they were all
knockoffs of each other yeah you know
everything was just kind of interrelated
yeah but it does have that it does have
that uh kind of veneer to it like that
kid does so it turns out so basically
the most of the movie is like a road
trip movie because like after the mom
gets shot
and then because Nick promised he would
take the kid out to see his dad so now
they have to do this road trip like I
said on a Greyhound bus from Florida to
Reno Nevada and the whole way
um because the gangsters
I guess because the um Terry O'Quinn
character who's his name is Frank in the
movie but he doesn't want to make the
designer drugs so basically the the
goons were like oh we're gonna kill your
family then so they kind of knew where
his ex-family lived like his wife and
kid and so they go and kill the wife and
now they're following
um you know Nick and the kid cross
country like while they're trying to get
to Reno and the the thing about it they
have
um a lot of the gangsters are just like
these [__] rednecks that's where a
lot of the like um the kind of comic
relief bit comes from I guess because
there's this one bit I think they're in
Kansas at one point
and there's this one bit like where this
the whole like cornfield truckload yeah
this whole truckload of jethros yeah are
like you know with all their like woohoo
and there's like coming after them like
in this [__] cornfield and there's a
whole thing yeah which that's kind of
true to the zatoichi movies yes the
gangsters in the in the zatoichi movies
were losers basically and uh clowns well
yeah all of them but most of them are
kind of clown
and uh they all get killed you you know
that's what you usually kills the ball
and there's always a few badasses in
there but they're mostly clowns
and I think they did a good job Rucker
Hower he he apparently like trained
really hard for this movie like because
he had to do all the sword play and he
had to pretend like he was blind at the
same time
and he does like a really passable job
of it I think so this came out it was a
good movie yeah yeah I mean it got our
attention you know it was in the action
adventure
genre in the in the VHS stores you know
it'd be alongside of Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie or a or a [__]
Phantom movie something like that you
know it was like martial arts type [__]
it was in that section
um and we liked it it was it's a lot of
fun I had a lot of fun with it actually
when I saw it I didn't know who sought
to which it was you know I did one until
later I saw the Japanese versions and I
realized oh okay that's where they got
this
but um
it was a well-made movie
um
Ford's budget you know this wasn't a
real high budget movie no definitely not
it's just um but for for action
adventure or action movie it was
actually
the quality was good
it was good and it was kind of a little
more
cerebral slash artistic
compared to the average say like Van
Damme movie or I don't want to say
Arnold's movie because some of my
Arnold's movies were [__]
masterpieces
um it's just
compared to the average one this one was
it wasn't as dumb as what you're saying
yeah comedy in it but it was it was
homaging something Americans had never
seen before which is a lot to each movie
yes there was a little bit it had like
it was a couple rungs above yeah plus
I'm always gonna say like Rucker Hower
like he's passed away now sadly
but I always kind of felt like he never
got to be as big a star as he should
have been and I feel like this movie was
maybe like his last
attempt at being like a big like
headlining action star and it just
didn't work out yeah and that sucks
because he's awesome I love Rucker
Howard yeah it didn't work out I was
there of course you know I didn't we
like we liked this movie and we we
Associated Rutger with [__] like [__]
Blade Runner and um The Hitcher The
Hitcher that kind of stuff Gotta Love
The Hitcher
he couldn't he didn't really make it
into the action scene because he
couldn't compete against Arnold and
Stallone and and Van Damme
he just wasn't [__] big enough in
terms of like he he'd have to go in
there and put on another 20 30 pounds of
muscle to be taken seriously or be some
kind of a [__] serious martial artist
I mean Van Damme wasn't that big but he
was in really good shape
and
um he did some goofy [__] back in the
day the [__] bad damn goofy [__]
photo shoots a ham in his underwear with
leopards and [__] [__] and just I
guess that in the European mindset that
was some cool [__] but it just looked
gay as [__] to an American but he just
he
damn Van Damme at least could do martial
arts
or at least yeah make you believe that
he could
there's you know there was always
if you weren't there back in the day
you'd never understand it it was
pre-internet it had Black Belt Magazine
stupid [__] [__] kung fu video games
and Mortal Kombat actually this is
pre-mortal combat we weren't quite sure
who could really fight and who couldn't
fight
fantasy would sometimes you know fantasy
and reality because sometimes it's hard
to tell apart
back in the late 80s especially if you
were young
like we thought maybe maybe a martial
artist maybe they could jump off to the
top of a [__] roof of a building I
mean [__] now we're talking about Ishita
Kim style [__] you know maybe maybe one
of them could make you go blind he
throws dirt in your face
but when you see a sheet of Kim who's a
[__]
she to Kim video when you see what that
actually looks like you saw how corny
that is you know ninja skills didn't
work he was just making that [__] yeah
yeah nib skills climbing under a window
look yeah and Van Damme eventually did
evidently get his ass kicked in a bar
fight so nobody knew what was true the
thing what I'm gonna argue Rucker Hower
he always had a lot more gravitas
um I'm gonna say I in my opinion he was
a better actor than any of the big
action Stars yeah um and he was more
versatile in the sense that he was
willing to play a villain AKA The
Hitcher yeah um whereas I kind of feel
like the action Stars they kind of were
very one-dimensional yeah in the sense
that they always want to be like this
heroic Larger than Life whereas Rucker
Howard seemed like he was more willing
to be like a real person and he was or a
bad guy he was more artistic yeah the
closest thing thank you Jeffy I heard
the closest thing to him that America
had would have been you know and in the
action in the action segment would have
been Stallone Stallone was real because
Rucker Howard was Dutch was he not I
think so I thought he was Dodge
um
because Stallone was also real talented
he could write he could act oh yeah out
of all the big um
I think was the books he's obviously
like the most talented in that because
like he wrote Rocky for fun yeah he
invented a lot of the characters that he
[__] like he invented John Rambo
you know and those movies were good wait
he had based it on other [__] to them
yeah it was based on a book because I
read the book actually the book is
actually good it's a lot different but
it was like it was like Spock okay
[__] Leonard no more didn't it didn't
didn't invent Spock but once he got the
role of Spock he expanded on it he made
Spock
Spock was a creation of [__]
Leonard Nimoy
I mean they were writing they were right
the writers were writing episodes around
something
Nimoy would say had to happen in the
character
oh we got to go to Vulcan you know that
kind of [__] we got to tell people how
how votans are different because he
would just Spock when they first came up
with the idea of Spock he was just a
generic alien they didn't know what fox
rules were
yeah they didn't really think about it
all that much no they were just going to
kind of he's like the token alien yeah
token alien and that was about that was
about as far as they went with it yeah
Leonard was like no this is my role
we're gonna [__] do something with
this he needs to do this
we need to know more of this
[__] he ended up becoming like the
[__] love interest in the [__]
whole series I mean the women were
looking at [__] Spock they weren't
looking at Kirk see I'm not so weird
yeah thank you even even our friend
[__] Laura Ross said that
says he is yeah she's a lot younger than
us and she recently got into the
original Star Trek series and she's like
holy [__]
no she's like Spock is like the hottest
and I was like see I told you yeah guys
like hurt
you know guys liked Kirk they like Spock
too I like Spock just that the women
were attracted to Spock because he was
he was uh he was he was the other
he was the guy you couldn't have
yeah well see he just goes to show they
never really know what's gonna appeal to
ladies more complicated yeah Spock was
hard to get
the hottest characters they ever put on
TV and I thought I was the weirdo
because yes I also had a crush on Lurch
from The Adams Family so you know
everybody thinks suddenly I'm the weirdo
okay but it's just like yeah other
people do like our induspective it's not
just me no
it's not just me being a weirdo even
though I'm used to being the weirdo it's
fine it's fine I've I've made my peace
with it uh next Dimension media said
Rucker was a great villain in Nighthawks
with Sylvester Stallone I haven't seen
that in a long time either I should we
should rewatch them remember that one
yeah you do a Rucker Hower yeah like I
saw that but I forgot that one I have to
see that one again
I think that was a sword and sorcery
movie wasn't it ooh Nighthawks wasn't
that something kind of like Beastmaster
I didn't think it was but it's like I
could be remembering it wrong yeah I
have to go back or confusing it with
something else I've seen so many movies
in my [__] life I just can't even
like remember them all anymore but the
thing about it what I was going to say
is that in this movie I think Rucker
Hower does a really good job balancing
because what he does he's which zatoichi
kind of does this too but he sort of
like pretends like he's oh I'm this
helpless bumbling blind man like
um but then he's kind of funny like he's
got like all these funny one-liners and
[__] like that but then if people like
try to like step up on his [__] and
everything like that he will absolutely
[__] waste you and then just be like
oh whoops don't even know where I'm
going with that I can't see anything
sorry you know what I mean and he just
like kills everybody I think Howard
Howard did a good job of it but shitaro
katsu man [__] was better at it I
mean
katsu Shin actually would get pretty
[__] dark in those movies yeah yeah
yeah I mean he'd be a clown and then the
next thing you know he'd be like it's
it's everything I can do to keep from
killing you that kind of [__] even you
know and it would sound real [__]
ominous you know and he yeah like mean
it and then you get all introspective
and [__] cry about what a loser he
was is another thing but that was like
only in someone it's a ride
what a loser and at the end of the Zachy
movies like when there's
like some of the last ones he was go on
about how
um
he wasn't a man anymore
that he had
he was a loser didn't have any money
women would have nothing to do with him
that he couldn't have sex anymore
because he had so much VD he just all
kinds of weird [__] he was like spilling
his all the VD
hookers
yeah just well now whose fault is that
yeah and then he'd go on a damn suicidal
[__] attack spree and kill like 30 or
40 dudes for a good cause type of deal
yeah it's okay if it's like for a good
cause yeah because yeah I mean Rucker
Howard kills a lot of people in this one
too but they're [__] so it's like
who cares well and the thing the funny
thing about it this is like every at 80s
action movie has this Trope where you
know he's a blind guy he wanders into
like a [__] Diner or something like
that to get a sandwich or whatever the
[__] and then as soon as he walks in
there's like a table of like miscreants
little bullies and there's like we're
just gonna go [__] with a blind dude
just for no reason yeah like you could
just sit there and drink your beer and
shut the [__] up but no they did that in
the movie because that's what happened
to satuichi movie yeah I know that's
what I'm saying but it's like in real
life it wouldn't have in real life
in real life but it happens in like
pretty much every 80s actually yeah and
then they'll all like surround you yeah
and then like they'll but they'll only
come at you one at a time conveniently
so you can like kick each one of their
asses it's more believable in athletici
movie because we were talking about like
the 1500s and maybe like some rotten
Samurai the 1500 would make fun of a
[__] blind bagger yeah look at this
guy let's get let's go [__] with a man
hey ever we gotta put a mouse in his
well yeah what they did in this one was
he goes in the thing and um the guy says
because he gets a burrito right yeah he
gets a burrito and the guy's like oh you
need some salsa on your burrito and then
he gives them like super super like
Atomic hot yeah sauce and then he like
eats it and he pretends it's super hot
and then he's just like ah it's not hot
enough and the guy's like what but then
he starts being like a [__] douche
about it and then like of course a woman
comes in and he has to like sexually
assault her and try to steal her person
and then you know wrecker Hammer has to
like [__] kill everybody but yeah so
but I think he did a good job like
balancing like the kind of goofy it's
not goofy necessarily but it is funny
like it does have a lot of comedic one
of the best sequences in this actually
one of my favorite sequences in this was
after they stole that van from the two
um thugs that the two thugs like
kidnapped them and was like driving them
but they got out and then they took the
van and obviously he can't drive because
he's blind and then the kid is only like
[__] 12 so he can't drive and then
the woman that was with them who I think
was
was Terry o'quinn's girlfriend right or
something and she loses her glasses
Velma style so she can't see either so
they're just like well who the [__]
gonna drive so the blind guy is driving
so there's this great [__] sequence
like through the streets of Reno of just
Rucker Howard just happily driving the
[__] van the wrong way down the
street like he can't see and it's just
like oh my God it's so funny but it's
like they staged it really well but um
but yeah so but he does a good job like
with the goofy stuff but also he looks
like he could
probably like do you know what I mean he
did like a lot of Sword training and
stuff like that so he does look like and
he's got the same thing that um zatuichi
has the the blade like inside his
walking stick yeah so he's got the same
thing and um I have to say too for fans
of martial arts films
there's a very funny bit where this
blind guy has pretty much like [__] up
most of this big gangster's Thugs and
he's just like what the [__] and so he
says to his little henchman or whatever
he's like bring me Bruce Lee you know
what I mean like and he literally says
that the dude's like pretty sure Bruce
Lee is dead well give me his brother
then so the guy that they get to fight
him is actually show kasugi who was in a
he was in a bunch of martial arts movies
I think Enter the Ninja is the one that
most people know him for but he's like
the big bad like at the end so him and
um him and Rucker how are like fight at
that did they bring in they bring in a
sword master
this big ass sword fight yeah cause
there's got to be a sword fight in this
out to which movie yeah that's just how
it is they did yeah that's just
happening lots of them we laughed our
ass off like when the first before he
fights the guy and he touches like
Rucker Howard touches show kazooie's
face because you know he's blind and
then he says oh Japanese and it was like
so he just feels like a Japanese person
I guess not reading his face like it's
Braille I guess I thought that was
really funny but it's like you know what
this is kind of like too it's a little
bit like um Daredevil yeah because
Daredevil was also blind but like his
other heightened uh senses are
heightened so he can like hear
everything and smell everything and he
knows where everybody is and when people
are [__] with him and [__] like that
so yeah it's almost like they're like
the magical blind person kind of Trope
but like I said zatsuichu is like that
too gotta say also other than the car
chase sequence which I really liked I
think my favorite part of this was the
thing where he was fighting the guy the
main like henchmen the Raising Arizona
guy who's what was that character's name
slag
yeah I think his name was slag yeah so
he was fighting that guy at the end and
I was like you know he's like he's got
wrecker Howard has this sword I was like
Somebody's gotta get beheaded come on
like somebody got a hand cut off like
with the gun still in it and then the
gun went off and that was super funny so
this is like pretty gory even though
it's kind of like a family-friendly
movie sort of
is it yeah it seems like family friendly
but then but then like I said Blake
people's limbs get cut off and [__] like
that so you know it was it was a PG
action movie for its time right so but
it's so so it's like so I thought it's
like oh slack better get his head cut
off at the end that would be awesome but
what happened is even better like the
final confrontation takes place up in
this like ski resort thing like so it's
like up in a mountain or something like
in Reno
and he like he [__] uh swings the
sword at him and the dude goes flying
off the cliff and he's cut in half so
like his little legs go this way and so
I was like oh my God that was so much
yeah I was like that was so much better
than a beheading what happened I was so
excited I was like he got like all cut
off and like [__] went down the
[__] hell it's like I was into it
what's funny about uh you know Blind
Swordsman
and uh Daredevil then
like there's actually a guy on YouTube
who's blind and uh loves rifles assault
rifles and stuff he owns them and he'll
do whole video reviews on he'll tell you
the whole history he's blind can't see
but yeah that's that's what blame means
yeah he can't see [__] but he can shoot
he's got videos of himself at the range
hitting man targets at 150 meters and he
could just the Buddy's calling out it
calling out what targets to hit and
he'll he can hit it he can hit him now
they're not moving and he's got to know
where they are
out to about 150 meters that's pretty
far without for not being able to see
did we ever talk about that guy I feel
like we brought up this guy before but I
saw a documentary about this one guy who
he's blind but he can do
um what do you call it uh echolocation
yeah like he taught himself to do
echolocation so he clicks and like he
from where the sound is bouncing off
like he can tell where everything is so
he goes out and like see and I don't
think he'll let him drive a car but he
goes out rides a bike and does all this
other kind of stuff and it's like he's
totally fine well that guy that I just
told you about to get hit he said
he said they made a horror movie like
that he could hear you coming down the
hallways and lay down fire he can hit
you by
like at basically echo location you hear
your footsteps and hear me stirring and
he knows the layout of his house so yeah
he's good with a gun and with in a
controlled environment I wouldn't [__]
with him
the [__] Turn All the Lights Off
you'd be in the dark and him he wouldn't
know any difference just like that movie
with Audrey Hepburn and wait until dark
yeah that's what that's what she meant
by [__] darkness is my Ally well
that's what she did at the end if you've
never seen I've reviewed it a while back
it's a classic Thriller by the way
Audrey Hepburn presented from the 60s
60s and um at the very end like the the
bad guy comes together and she's blind
like I said and she hasn't been blind
her whole life she's just recently blind
and she turns off all that she smashes
all the lights in the apartment so
they'll be on even footing yeah problem
is she forgets one light which is the
light inside the refrigerator okay which
most people would probably forget to so
it's you know you can't blame her too
much for that but because I totally
wouldn't wouldn't have thought of that
but she did like think so that that was
where the final like Battle Royale took
place and I think when they showed it in
the theater like they turned all the
lights off in the theater so it would be
it would be like immersive and stuff
but yeah so we just like I said we just
kind of came across this randomly you
know we were kind of in the mood it was
but not long it was between this movie
and The Wraith yeah like because Amazon
Prime had both of those and they were
like right now because I said I'm kind
of in the mood for like an 80s uh kind
of underrated situation and I had seen
The Wraith before but not for a really
long time but this one I hadn't seen I'd
heard of it but I had never watched it
but Tom said he'd seen it and he's like
oh we should watch that I remember that
being pretty good and you know I'm
always down to like watch something with
Rucker Howard because I love him yeah
and I had never seen this one and he's
looking tight in it too he looks good
yeah this was
when did The Hitcher come out this was
three years after The Hitcher The
Hitcher I think came out in 1986.
so I think this was three years after
that because in good shape because like
I said he was in a lot of [__] after
this obviously because somebody pointed
out he was in hobo with a shotgun I
think that was his last movie which is
also a great film by the way
but
oh you would probably like OK Google you
probably like her but with a shotgun but
yeah he's in I think that was his last
movie before he died but um but yeah I
kind of feel like this was his last
you know it like his last try to get
like that big action movie status like
you know like Schwarzenegger and
Stallone and them had and you or even
like Bruce Willis or something like that
but it's just he's he always seemed like
he never got through to that like a list
timing wasn't right which is a shame
because he's great when he appeared he
had to have physically been bigger kind
of royed it out to compete with those
other guys than they would because that
was actually one of the main attractions
of that of that genre was how big those
guys were how muscular they were or how
big they could make them look too like
Stallone isn't very big
um but he can look big on screen I think
he's maybe five eight
but he's gonna puffing himself up like a
cat
was in great shape though
he was in great shape for a Demolition
Man he was in great shape for [__] uh
Rambo three he was amazing I mean he was
he just gotten he just uh gotten done
doing a whole bunch of training with
[__] think it was Frank Zane who was
a famous bodybuilder I think was his
trainer and he looked [__] great and
uh Rambo three Rambo 3 was like a
[__] just a kill Fest it was
pure action movie ridiculous action
movies everything blowing up uh machine
guns everywhere
that was that was just a wild was that
the one with all the gore no no no that
was that was that was that was Rambo the
Fight continued that's really good that
was just like a straight up yeah
bloodbath yeah which is hence why is his
best one hence why I like that one yes
yeah it was a great movie and then when
he came back later his face was fixed up
Gary look yeah they got to fix it yes he
ain't fixed it but um it didn't matter
man it didn't matter if his face looked
[__] up in that movie that was a
[__] badass [__] movie and his
body looked great though I would love to
know what the body count of that movie
was I'm sure someone's counted it was
fun there's got to be a website out
there with like you know what's the body
count of the movie ever that somebody
counts all of them you just kind of took
Rambo three and put it on [__]
steroids yeah it's just it was just like
a Non-Stop Massacre pretty much that
movie John Gore said Recker Howard was
great in flesh and blood which was uh
Paul verhoven's first English language
film had Jennifer Jason Lee too yeah and
she was also in the picture I don't
think I've ever seen that now that
you're now that you're talking about it
isn't now am I mistaken but didn't Anne
Rice say that when she wrote The Vampire
Lestat she was picturing wrecker Hower
as Lestat I don't know and that's all
and that's how that's why she was kind
of mad initially when they announced
that Tom Cruise was going to be in the
movie because she had pictured somebody
more like Rucker Hower although I at
that point like Rucker Howard probably
been a little bit too old yeah to play
the vampireless app but that's I
remember reading that that's who she was
picturing when she was writing the
character from what I remember Lestat
was turned into a vampire when he was 16
or 17.
what wouldn't that right
I thought he was 18 but yeah it's been a
long time I remember thinking when I was
reading those books back a long time ago
but she wrote those books in the 70s and
80s so like Rucker Howard was young but
that's who she was picturing like I
remember reading those books back in
this back in the day
thinking that wait a minute what she's
describing this Louis and and Lestat
would have been teenagers
basically yeah they would have appeared
to be teenagers yeah to everybody else
but they they weren't they were old
this is kind of a weird concept and
she's writing basically vampire porn
that gay vampire porn well yeah you know
why do you think it involved a very
young guy why do you think it sold so
well yeah involved in very young
or at least they looked young they were
[__] the stat was already a couple
hundred years old by the time it
happened
Tammy said yeah because Lestat was over
six feet yeah he was he was a big dude
yeah I think she ended up thinking that
saying that Tom did a good job with it
though yeah she was mad about it at
first like she took out ads and
everything and a lot honestly like I
couldn't blame her because I was not
picturing Tom Cruise in that [__]
thing he did he was good he was good I
don't love Tom Cruise but he was
actually man [__] he did he nailed it
about
the stop being a [__] snotty ass dick
and Tom Cruise is real good at playing
Parts like that but likable
man you're a [__] dick dude you know
and yet still I'm hanging out with kind
of cool yeah brennaire said I bet she
was picturing Rucker Howard as he looked
in Flesh and Blood the one we were
talking about uh he was pretty young in
that that's what I thought because she
wrote that book well I know Interview
with the Vampire came out in 1976 right
and then Lestat when did the Vampire
Lestat come out
a couple years after that or was that 81
I can't remember but it was like it was
70s and 80s that she was writing that so
when she said that she was picturing
lasat looking like Rucker Howard she was
talking about him like from then yeah
from like the early 80s so and he was
real young man so like it was like Blade
Runner time yeah so well that was a
great record it was 82 so that might
have been he was already older so he was
already a little bit older I don't know
how like old he was but
but yeah
um
Samantha Bee said uh Tom Cruise still
sends Kirsten Dunst a birthday cake
every year yeah sweet or weird I can't
decide no nice I guess that's nice yeah
she's a grown woman yeah yeah
I guess and she wasn't young really it
wasn't as young as she appeared in that
movie I think she was
she was 14 when she 14 or 15. she was
something like that yeah she was like a
teenager they were trying to pass her
off as like 12 but she was because like
I think in the book she was about that
age no in the book she was like six six
yeah in the book she was six six that's
right that's why it's like nobody has
the balls till I [__] make a six year
old and I don't I don't blame him I'm
not saying I want to see that
necessarily I'm just saying that in the
book she was six years old which been a
long time since I've read it that's the
thing it causes like a lot more problems
if you're that little yeah like being
made into a vampire obviously right
her mom was dead though they found her
in a BL in a plague Zone and she had the
plague she was gonna Dodge
they made her a vampire to keep her
dying
and he gave her to Louise a gift
but still I can understand like being a
little bit mad about being like
eternally six years old she would have
died anyway that's true but I'm just
saying
that that would still be like she lived
a long time I think she was 50 when in
the I think she was 50 in the in in the
story when she died Yeah well yeah she
got murdered by the other family did you
have vampires killed her well you know
if you guys have never read the vampire
Chronicles man [__] read it they're
real good at least the first three are
good I'd read all of them oh yeah
they're all good but the first men not
the devil and all the all the the branch
the [__] that branched off I didn't get
into the witch stuff but I liked the I
liked the witch ones the Mayfair witches
I liked the I liked that series but it's
been a while for that I have most of
them around here someplace I just
haven't read them in such a long time
but I got super into them like when I
read them the first time
they were good they were real good yeah
I like better than the movies like you
said they're very immersive well there's
so much more detail this is a true 99.99
of the time the book is always going to
be better because
it's not limited in scope you can write
down whatever you want paper's cheap you
know what I mean or you know pixels are
cheap if you're just gonna read the
ebook so you can make the [__] thing
2 000 pages long and put as much [__]
detail in there as you want when you're
making a movie you're limited and and
all the kind of vampire lore that I like
and like the great movies that I think I
I include [__] um uh Mama wall day in
other words Blacula Blacula screen black
in the screen uh because Anne Rice used
those as a template for the vampire
Chronicles because those movies
addressed what would vampire culture be
like yeah and in the unedited versions
of black in the screen black in the
screen to show you
what [__] vampire culture is like you
no you can't go out at night and hang
out with The Mortals wearing badass
clothes no you can't that you will bring
them back here and he's like well wait a
minute hold on
I'm a vampire and I gotta do what you
say yeah so I'm a slave yeah
vampire sorry man that's how it goes
vampires made slaves out of other
vampires
and that's what that basically that the
vampire Chronicles about it's a
hierarchy of vampires
and basically a lot of them are slaves
did Riker Howard ever play a vampire in
a movie I don't know
hmm
I thought
what he might have but now I can't
remember
I don't know
I don't think so probably not probably
not he's been a lot we're getting way
off topic though this what else is new
yeah what else is new but yeah so if you
have Amazon Prime and you like 80s
action movies with like a little bit of
funny [__] in it and you also like
zatoichi movies and you want to see like
an American take on it and you like
Rucker Hower then it's a no-brainer you
should definitely check this one out
like I said I don't really see I saw
like a lot of reviews for it when I went
looking
but I hadn't really hurt anybody like
talking it's not like it's some big like
cult classic or anything like that in
the sense that everybody knows
it you know
but it definitely seems like a second or
third tier cult classic because I did
find a lot of reviews of it and a lot of
people that reviewed it
remembered it very fondly from their
childhoods yeah you know what I mean
like from the from the 90s it's like
yeah we rented this all the time but we
love this [__] movie when we were
kids because it was on cable all the
time and I can totally see that because
this movie like I said it's not long
it's only like 90 minutes and it's super
entertaining yeah like it's just like
pretty action-packed and it's also it's
got kind of a nice
um
a little bit of like an emotional heart
to it because you get a thing where
there's there's kind of a a running
thing where I guess when Rucker Howard's
character got blinded by the mortar
explosion in Vietnam which blinded him
um which I said that twice sorry about
that but um but it also like [__] up
his tear ducts so he can't cry so
there's like this kind of uh discussion
that he has with the kid because the
kids crying about his mom dying to be
like oh my God I'm such a [__] because
I'm crying he doesn't say that but you
know what I mean that's kind of the gist
of it and he's just like oh you know a
real man's never afraid to cry and all
this stuff and I'm like wow that's
really nice and then like at the very
end when he gives the kid you know he
saves the kid he saves the dad he kills
all the bad guys and [__] like that and
then he gives the kid back to the dad
and the kid has kind of gotten very fond
of him he calls him like Uncle Nick you
know what I mean and and uh so but he's
got to go on because he's like zatoichi
or Kung Fu or something like that he's
got to like go on to the next adventure
like he can't just hang around so him
and the kid like leave and the kids like
crying like don't go I'll go dig and all
this other stuff and then like he cries
at the end now they did set it up
because when we watch the ending you
were like well they could make this a
sequel because they did kind of I don't
know if they like set it up but they
made it left it open yeah um and they
actually were when they made this they
were actually thinking of making a
sequel I could tell but um those things
had sequels back but they just never got
around to it because it didn't do well
enough
um but yeah they could have made like a
whole like series out of this where he
was going from place to place the
problem with the movie I think the
reason why it
go over big GS I saw it
I liked it
but it I wasn't too curious about what
was going to happen next and I didn't
quite really understand what I was
seeing 100 of the time
after seeing zatoichi movies now I saw
this one I was like oh of course
I liked a lot better after seeing some
soft Twitchy moves because I know I knew
what they were it gives you some context
I knew what they were homaging and
knowing and it'll it allows you to know
why they're shooting certain scenes like
he's walking away the kids crying and uh
he's said [__] it I'm I'm I got to leave
this kid behind so he'll bond with his
dad that's like some [__] is out to eat
you would do and those scenes would be
shown yeah at the end of a zato
be [__] up about how he could be
living a life with these people but he
can he's a Wandering loner like Kane
from [__] yeah like from like this is
the path I have chosen yeah gotta go if
not we can't make another movie
with a different story I did my [__] I
gotta go
okay another story says I watch Blind
Fury as an adult and I like it a lot
Rucker Howard can be a good guy but I
much prefer him as the bad guy she is
not to which a movie if you like this go
see something yeah I mean that's the
thing it's like yeah he's he's great is
a good guy and he's great in this
um but yeah he probably does make a
better villain just but I mean he's very
when he's a villain he's like really
intimidating because he's kind of
charming at the same time which makes
him even more intimidating
so yeah but like I said I think that
might have been a reason too why he
didn't get to like the top tier action
stars because he was willing to play
villainous roles like he did in the
pitcher and
you know Arnold Schwarzenegger he was
right about that that's why he didn't
want to play a villain because he just
wanted that heroic action star
kind of Larger than Life character play
a villain too much it ruins your brand
yeah and and he did realize that but the
thing about it is that the villains are
always more interesting like always
they're always more interesting but they
get killed yeah and then the the
audience starts seeing you getting
killed all the time yeah so you're not
indestructible
although Tom Cruise decided to be a
Ville in [__] collateral see and he
makes a great villain yeah because he's
because like I said he's he seems like
he's kind of a jerk so it's like so he's
just channeling Cruz is actually a
better villain than he is he is yeah
well because when he tries to be a hero
it's just like too much it's just kind
of like he's like too perfect or like
too good at everything but like when
he's a villain and he just like allows
himself to just like go full-on [__]
he's a lot more he's so much better yeah
and like kind of like which is weird
like that but he is more likable when
he's a villain he was a very likable to
stop the start's a villain because
you're cool because you're not you
because you get the sense that you're
seeing the real him yeah that he's not
like trying to put on a face for him
when he's playing a good guy I get the
sense that it's like fake when he was
playing that is that that hit hit man at
a collateral you buy it he was [__]
nuts he liked killing people and it just
like he was real good at it real good
shot and Tom is good with guns he's real
good with guns he's got real training
and some of the [__] the [__] I'm doing
in the movies is a little far-fetched
now nobody's really that fast and that
yeah but it's a movie it's a movie
nobody's really that fast and that
accurate with pistols people want to see
cool [__] in movies but I don't care if
it's realistic you do have some guys
like that they're competition Shooters
but they're doing that under the under
the conditions of a competition not
combat nobody's firing back at him
that's a it's it's like it's not quite
the same I saw her little butt turned up
behind you no no Keanu Reeves is also
good with guns I've seen him at the
range videos of him he's very good very
good at close range
but just because he's good don't don't
think that that [__] that you see
in his movies as far as is plausible or
feasible
like that close range hand-to-hand
martial arts with pistols doesn't work
out
everybody gets shot everybody well like
I said they're not instant there is an
instant incapacitation usually you can
take a couple rounds and then fire back
and either I mean after you've been shot
a few times so it's so both guys get
shot well like I said nobody wants to
necessarily see realistic [__] in movies
yeah people want to see cool [__] yeah
you know what I mean it's okay if it's
not realistic people know it's not
smoking yeah those movies just making us
cool or they're real good and they're
like we need to watch that one next I
think it's streaming which one that last
[__] can of ribs the John Wick one
John Wick was it John Wick four four
yeah I still want to see that yeah
because I really liked all the other
things I think I think you can uh stream
it now well you should be able to they
got it for sale at the at the Dollar
General right by the register four yeah
it's Blu-ray or DVD yeah they got the
Blu-ray I'm gonna get that yeah they
just I don't remember how much it was
but they had it right by the register
and the last time I was there getting
some coffee we'll get that tomorrow
okay yeah we'll just go over there and
get it on your motorcycle like 10 bucks
I don't know anything 24. well yeah I
don't know I don't know well I mean it's
been out for a while so I imagine like
it can't um yeah it's not that much to
stream one new movie that's come out
like a horror movie that I want to see
is called cobweb and a lot of people
have been talking about that and I think
you can rent that for 6.99 but I might
wait till it comes down a little bit
Expendables four I saw that I saw the
trailer today on [__] YouTube it
looks great and I like three that's
gonna be out in the theater soon I think
yeah because I keep seeing the poster
and see that
theatrical cut of three wasn't very good
now you can put that on [__] on oh
[__] Mr no cousin what's his name
[__]
octagon [__]
Chuck Norris Chuck Norris yeah Chuck
Norris kind of ruined three
but well Chuck Norris kind of ruined
yeah I think you don't allow any cussing
did it although I will cut a bunch of
cool [__] one thing like we were
thinking about we were scrolling through
movies last night because we were going
on Amazon Prime and 2B and everything
like that
and I was like they did have silent rage
on there and I said now I will concede
I've seen not like under duress all of
the Chuck Norris movies my ex-husband
was like the world's biggest Chuck
Norris fan and for whatever reason and
um I don't really get the Chuck Norris
thing I don't get it either but so like
I ended up watching all of the Chuck
Norris movies yes even the dog one yes
even the one where they go to hell or
whatever so yes so I've seen them all
but I will concede that silent rage is
actually a good ish Chuck nor it's good
for a Chuck Norris movie okay because
it's kind of like a horror movie well he
[__] up three because he made him not
cuss
you can't be at a movie that has cussing
in it ain't that some childish [__]
but I wouldn't even be able to talk if I
couldn't yeah but you what the [__] is
that about listen some if I'm if I'm in
a [__] bar and somebody
[__] says I can't cuss or I punch
that [__] all right which I've had that
happen to me before in bars in
Mississippi I'm talking to somebody else
and don't be cussing around my wife I
should have [__] decked that
[__] but I wasn't as big what
century is this again
it was it was
it was the [__] around of times it was
to find out
today
the [__] out in front of your wife and
she will never look at you the same ever
again
I mean of all the things like look I'm
an advocate like if somebody is really
[__] around and they're being a real
annoying ass I would have turned him I
was talking to somebody else well that's
what I mean if somebody's really [__]
around and being an annoying ass or
something like that yeah like absolutely
stop doing what you're doing like that's
legit but if somebody's talking to
somebody they're not even talking to you
and they're not yelling or anything like
that and they're just swearing because
people swear yeah and like don't you
come over to me I was in my 20s early
40s you know what I mean so he thought
he could pull Rank and it was
Mississippi and it was another time if
it happened today I just beat the [__]
out of it in front of his wife
and then probably leave with his wife if
I was single
yeah because they never look at you the
same way then like put a cigarette out
yeah on that [__] walk out with his
[__] flat-chested wife
and then call him a [__]
[__]
[Laughter]
that defend
Expendables 3.
because
um
the uncut version on the Blu-ray is far
superior it's good real good one of the
best ones
and and that Chuck Norris had him cut
all the good [__] out of it
why does anybody listen to Chuck Norris
about anything he wouldn't be in a movie
unless it was dead to his status
for some reason nobody needs something
worse than the body had to have him in
there just for name you know he wanted
him in there Sly yeah I was
nobody needs Chuck Norris and they were
asking they've been if he's gonna be
they've been asking stuff [__] Steven
Seagal to come on but he won't come on
he's afraid they're gonna make fun of
him I guess well duh yeah obviously
they're like yeah that that's why we're
putting you in the movie so we can make
fun of you
no no no
they don't have to do it that way you
could put him in they don't have to in a
villain role but that's how it's going
to turn or you can put him in a role
that is appropriate that people will
understand it it would be good
well they could make him like Jabba the
Hutt or something no
no no no no
I'm getting mad
I know it's so easy to like exasperate
you yeah
about the thing about [__]
all right
he had a couple good movies yes we know
he had a couple good ones [__] Under
Siege one and two good ish yeah [__]
hard to kill I thought was pretty good I
mean for that genre yeah okay they were
okay
um
the amazing thing about Seagal is that
he's got some Die Hard fans
so you can't [__] off you can't piss off
as fast you have to have him in a role
that kind of homages his late career
that's how I would do it
you know what I mean when he dresses up
like a ninja and ninja ninja vampire
Samurai with a painted on hair and
[__] that the hanging around with a
with a 17 year old Japanese girl who
loves him in a pool of Asian experience
I used to experience energy drink and
[__] I want somebody yeah if y'all love
me y'all would send me Steven Seagal
action figure I'll put that [__] right
here
I want to steam just to go how cool
would it be if we had like a lot like a
life-size like a larger than life size
like the one that I have of Mirror
Universe action figure of all [__]
things but the thing about it is if we
had a larger than life Steven Seagal
cardboard cutout and he would put it in
front of the Spock it would cover a spot
completely up because it would be super
wide yeah so have [__] cigar along
this [__]
he's Steven Seagal still hasn't come to
our house and has like threatened to
beat us up yet so I guess we're okay all
the [__] I talk about
to go I got a strange kind of [__]
Fascination for Steven Seagal I think a
lot of people have a stranger I also
have a strange fascination with him just
because
I'm I'm always like mystified by people
that are that
arrogant and also that cluelessness
clueless about their own
um shortcomings
they only want to put it in that way man
I just I I just look at Steven Seagal on
some of the early talk shows that he
that he went on
when they're asking it or they'd ask him
[__] invasive questions of you know
did you ever lived did you ever live in
Japan and he's like trying to say yes
but he can't or there's all kinds of
work he doesn't want to outright live
but he's trying to like yeah yeah make
it and run around it right and
he did know that that one martial art
but I'm not sure if that's an effective
martial I think it's a keto I think is
what it's called I don't think it's very
effective
uh it's very old school
from another time
you know I think it was mostly about
defending yourself against a sword
really I think is what it was based on
which you know that that might be useful
information yeah but that's nothing
compared to MMA well no you know
um so he could do
that
but he wanted to claim that he could do
a whole lot more than that you know like
advise the CIA on [__] and [__] help
people see that's what's fast do exact
kind of [__] it's fascinating to me like
okay I get people that are complete
losers and have never done anything in
their life and they make up lies just to
make themselves seem better but it's
like if you're actually kind of
accomplished like you know what I mean
like he's not a [__] superhero or
anything like that but he was like in
some very well regarded movies he could
actually kind of do martial arts he had
like he could do [__] yeah but then he
just felt the need to just Guild the
Lily yeah and I don't and and in a way
that made it really easy to like
demonstrate that he was making it up
yeah and I don't really understand like
the motivation behind I think what
happened was is he heard Frank Dukes lie
a lot and he's like oh I believed I
could do that
I think he believes a lot of people
believed Frankton and and so he felt
like sorry Dukes I'm saying Ducks I'm
gonna say ducks yeah put an um loud on
it if you want us to pronounce it yes
I'm gonna say Frank ducks
I think he heard Frank ducks
tell all them lies and he thought they
were true and that he had to compete
with that
maybe that's what it was so he felt like
he felt like inadequate yeah
because it's like you run into that
sometimes you're one of these people
that just like say just like
outrageously you know is not true you
know it's not true yeah and it's just
kind of and it's very easy to check that
it's not you know what I mean it's like
and call them out on it but it's like
they'll never admit that they're just
like making it up and I don't understand
that like that's
that's just fascinating to me that
personality type Mr demographic that
this what this is great
we don't know exactly well I think that
was probably about we were talking about
the swearing yeah yeah Tammy says oh by
the way Kristen Dunst was only 11. when
she was in Interview with the Vampire
but like I said so yeah about right but
like I said she was six in the book yeah
Brenner said I think playing a villain
is way harder than playing the good guy
anyway I agree I think it is too well
the villains are usually a lot more
um layered and a lot more uh complex
yeah uh the whole movie's focus is on
the villain the good guy's job is to
react all the work is on the villain
yeah I would agree with that I would
agree with that yeah so she was 11
working on there but you know she was
just working with everybody else and I
guess they they knew her so you know Tom
[__] sent her the gifts and [__] he's
like he's Uncle Tom you know Uncle Tom
I'll tell you what man
showed up to do [__] Spider-Man and
she played what was her name
was Spider-Man's girlfriend's name Mary
Ellen Mary and Mary [__] Marianne no I
forgot very soon oh [__]
she was cute as [__] it just totally
like went on she was cute as hell in
this
Mary Jane Mary Jane I knew his Mary's
not there just like like the shoe yeah
you think of all people I would know
that because that's my favorite she's as
great as Mary Jane John Gore said I
liked Cruz and Tropic Thunder yeah he
was great in that that's another you
need to see that yeah you need to see
that movie everybody says you would
[__] love that movie you would love
that movie yeah that's and it's hard
it's usually hard for me to predict what
movies you would like but but Tropic
Thunder that's right up your [__]
alley I think you would like that a lot
Brenner said Rucker Hower in Nighthawks
is just a master class and playing a
villain he did it so well it intimidated
Stallone and Stallone had the film
re-edited to make Stallone look better
on screen
see now we really have to re-watch it
because Stallone was so insecure that
he's like he the bad guy is just like
too bad and he looks like he's
scaring me so I have to fix it yeah
brennaire said that's the Norris film
where he's basically fighting a slasher
villain yeah silent Rage that's that's
why that's the only way okay the Octagon
is good too
but I haven't seen it a long time but I
remember that one being all right
but silent rage is kind of like I don't
want to say it's like Silence of the
Lambs because it's not as good as
Silence of the Lambs obviously but it's
kind of along the same lines where it's
like a like a
is it Supernatural isn't he Supernatural
kinda who the guy the villain in um
silent rage
I thought he had some kind of I don't
know if it was like a superpower or it
was some kind of like something psychic
or I don't remember something but he was
like a serial killer yeah I don't
remember the movie at all yeah but I I
tend to like like when the action movies
like cross over a little bit because
didn't [__] um
what was that one that uh that um
[__] what's his [__] name
now I can't remember Death Wish Charles
Bronson yeah Charles Bronson did one
called
what the [__] was the name of it was it
10 to midnight
but I thought he did one too that was
kind of more like it wasn't a horror
movie but it was more like a thriller
type of thing and that I remember liking
that one a lot
but his best one was what was it called
the mechanic
the professional the mechanic yeah I
think it was called the mechanic Charles
Bronson yeah yeah did we review that one
not something Jan Michael Vincent was in
it yeah yeah yeah he played an assassin
yeah that's it yeah we were reviewed
that yeah nikonos left a subplot big but
he's gay and he's got a thing yeah
that's right he brings on Jan Michael
Vincent as an apprentice and that's
right and like a boyfriend and they were
like serial killers killing these dudes
for the mafia that's right it was a
great one I remember really liking that
yeah and
process said he liked the carrot he
wanted to think but he didn't want to
play a gay character he thought they
might hurt his brand so he asked him to
kind of leave that vague
yeah so they yeah they kind of but I
mean if you watch it nowadays it's
pretty clear yeah
um yeah that that's but they tried to
like kind of keep it on the download but
yeah if you watch it nowadays it's like
pretty obvious it's obvious to to
today's audience yeah but back then
maybe not he wasn't quite as obvious of
what was what was going but it's
definitely he's definitely coded yeah he
was just a psychopathic
serial killer who was acting as a damn
assassin
and he was gay and he brought in a young
pretty boy as an apprentice and turned
him into a damn yeah that's right kill
the machine and then
they turn on each other in the end over
some [__] well you know that come out
70s right yeah it was good it was like
something out of it's one of those damn
serial killer cases we'd hear you know
what's his name old [__]
Carl that was his name when it was
torturing the little boys on the board
oh yeah was that guy's name Coral Dean
Coral yeah kind of like a more Mafia
version of Decor that [__]
horrible that dude yeah we did a show
about them man if I got all his ass him
and his glass rods
uh
[__] I was just like listening to one of
those scary story channels on the way
home and he was getting into like all uh
Leonard Lake and Charles ing again yeah
I was like ah I forgot what those two
sadistic ass [__] yeah they
needed to die slowly wait yeah we did a
show about them too those are all yeah
there's some like the worst of the word
conventional white Mass Justice couldn't
bring Justice to those two they'd have
to pull out a [__] like me to
bring Justice to that you know you know
outside of society I'd get their asses
and the sad thing about it is that no
matter what you did to them like they
wouldn't learn no it'd be nothing
compared to what they did to those women
yeah that too but uh I'd sleep more
soundly at night
yeah so I'd be doing a kind for selfless
reasons yeah I get it yeah yeah because
it's not gonna do anything for them like
they're it's not going to teach them
anything no just make me feel better
about it yeah
yeah I get I'm perfectly willing to
admit that yeah it's like I know it's
not gonna like help them like they're
not gonna be like oh my God and they're
gonna see the error their ways because
people like that just don't there's a
certain Zen
in
there's a sin in allowing things to
remain [__] up but there's another
kind of a Zen to to write something
you know yeah and if it and you're
writing it in an unconventional way
I'm not a big believer in
the conventional system and nah
fantasy
John Gore said Sly should have put Mr T
in The Expendables people would have
loved him yeah I think I would have
rather seen him in there doesn't look
like he used to though well nobody looks
like yeah people get old [__] big
film at 11.
yeah you know the right [__] you can
stay big till you die well I know that
but I'm just saying that it's like
everybody gets older I'm not sure if Mr
T was on on the sauce I don't think he
was I I had to go back and look at him
no he probably was I haven't seen him in
a while it probably was I'd have to go
back and look at his physique why can I
feel like everybody who doesn't love Mr
C Chuck Norris is a little bit a little
bit more of a divisive figure I feel he
was he was great in that one Rocky film
when he was in the beginning of it
remember that because yeah yeah is that
your woman you know he's talking about
Adrian remember that okay I forgot what
he said I mean who doesn't love Mr
Speaker he had his own breakfast cereal
back in the 80s do you guys remember
that Mr Cheese here so they made the
commercials [__] yeah he had about
[__] seven inches of gold gold chains
going around that was his thing Man it
worked that [__] must have went they
were real they must have weighed a lot
of spent about 30 pounds of [__] gold
either that or they were plastic yeah I
mean that's what I would have done yeah
yeah John Gore said uh Rodriguez put
Steven Seagal on one of his machete
films it's the second one I think
oh really I've seen the first machete
but I don't think I ever saw the second
one
now we gotta watch that we're gonna see
Steven Seagal waddling around in there
was he waddling I don't even remember
when that movie came out so I don't know
how heavy it was at that time but I
don't know we'll see all right Jeff
Earhart said Norris believes his own
press yeah and again that's that's a
personality type that I have a hard time
it's I find it fascinating but I have a
hard time like relating to
like people that just get so
um
swallowed by their own myth I guess
and also like he takes himself too
seriously which is again an issue that I
have with Steven Seagal also it's like
you can't be too you can't get to a
point where you just like take yourself
so seriously that like no one can have a
laugh at your expense or you just like
are so self-important
that you think you're like above the
[__] rabble and everything like that
it's just like I don't really understand
that
and but the thing about it though is
that's what makes it easier to like poke
fun at them because they just are just
so self-important that it becomes
hilarious
he didn't have any much about him to be
that way anyway it was that was the part
well they never do just lying on like
someone that's actually awesome wouldn't
actually have to do that well he could
do some [__] but he had to add on to it
and that's what I'm saying and then he
just become a cop on TV
where he's [__]
style [__] I don't remember exactly who
was serving he had a whole [__]
that I think that entire series is on 2B
yeah okay let's go see that I've seen a
few of the episodes he would probably be
he is a cop in there it'd be super
cringe or something well he's an
honorary but they let him do cop [__]
let him do cop [__] it's [__]
ridiculous and uh I would not let Steven
Seagal do cop [__] and uh he's whatever
race of person he's talking to if you're
white he's white if you're black he
becomes black if if you're if you're
Asian he becomes Japanese if you just if
he starts talking about Japan he becomes
Japanese he's a trip man
chameleons
if he starts talking about soul food he
becomes black he's from Michigan and
he's Jewish he has nothing to do with
that [__] come on
although he can't play guitar
you can play guitar pretty good which
why did he just stick with that well see
that's what I mean it's like look he
can't actually do [__] some people can't
do anything right he can do a few things
relatively well yeah just take that roll
with it
um you know you don't have to be humble
about it you can be like yeah I can do
this kind of [__] but don't exaggerate
he was you're not like God's Gift he was
doing that cop [__] here in the South I
think that was him I thought it was
Arizona but
I could be wrong I thought it was
Arizona or Texas I also saw him running
around Louisiana though too he's doing
he did something Louisiana for what I
just noticed that when he was in the
South he tried to be a southern sound as
Southern as possible dudes from Michigan
yeah no we see you Stephen singall
you're a Yankee dude
I mean and like I said there's nothing
right just be what you're be what you
are like don't pretend to be something
you're not especially nowadays because
people can check up check on your [__]
yeah and no one's gonna get a trust you
or believe you in anything so you just
keep making just be what you're like man
it's all right it's too late for him he
he ran he ran off to Russia
well I mean and the thing about it is
the Asian experience got got old and now
he's just like well now he's just like a
punchline and so like you said it's
probably too late to like retina himself
at this point because now yeah now
whatever he comes out and says he could
like [__] he could legitimately find
the cure for cancer yeah like he's not
gonna he's not gonna do that obviously
but he will come out and say that and
everybody's like [__] off you did not
it's my understanding he's got like
several dozen kids
and like I think like several times well
that does not surprise yeah like several
dozen kids and like it's mostly from
like Eastern European and Russian moms
that's the end well that's what happens
he goes up and gives him a free
allegedly a free breast exam yeah one
thing leads to another he's a shiatsu
master and then he's gonna find some
lumps in your lumps this is a big lump
this is like a double cheat love
the other one
are you lactating
I swear
okay it's I feel a hard lump in this one
let me check the other one again yeah
he's like you know if you let me drink
your milk that's supposed to cure cancer
I I found that out in my laboratory if I
can if I can get a taste I can tell
whether or not that's [__] that's
whether that's cysts I would bet real
American money that he actually did say
that at least one person I can tell
about your breast it would not Shock me
at all your breast health yeah yeah if
you approached a woman that was pregnant
or had just given birth and legit
straight up asked her to drink yeah her
breast milk that's right so he could
give her a so he'd give it an assessment
assessment of her memory of her health
yeah
that would not Shock Me In This lightest
like I said I would I would bet money
yeah that he had said that to at least
one person ah yeah he'd do that that's
that's totally on brand
[Laughter]
Tom's gonna drink some breast milk
somewhere
I got him on the lookout now
I'm gonna carry a [__] wine Goblin
titties etched in it legs are hatched in
the front
yeah I'm gonna carry some of those
strips of paper so I can do tests and
[__] in there and go okay yeah your pH
balance is good listen to that dude I'll
have a whole thing I have it in a
[__] medicine bag hey that would
actually that's a great idea for a video
breast doctor yeah well you know I do
like we could even if we could do a fake
one because like I could put on like a
fake pregnant belly and like all that
other kind of stuff and we'll hook it up
so you squirt yeah yeah yeah and it's
like and then you get to like come up
and I'll pretend I don't know you and
[__] like that and then like you could
just come up and be like Steven Seagal
and like yeah yeah I'll dress up as
Stevens go
that would be even funnier yeah just
paint it up yeah put it on there with a
marker like just kind of happen I think
it's six two that's okay yeah
you're like what happened to you you
shrank
well yeah it's like you know I got put
in the dryer yeah that's still wet but
yeah so that would actually be like a
really funny video I don't know if I
could keep a straight face the whole
time but that that would be pretty
hilarious and you know that there'd be
freaks out there that would watch that
yeah well I mean lactation that's a
whole sub-genre yeah so we could hire
some talent that does that
make it real
yeah you could do a rolling too you did
it real yeah we'll figure out something
we'll tell you doctor with her yeah we
needed Joseph as a doctor you're dressed
up as a nurse
we had to write out all these guys we
have good ideas for this [__] all the
time yeah we'd ever write him down that
we forget but that is actually a good
idea we'll just have to we'll dress up
like some kind of Clockwork Orange
remember how they went to the [__]
boloco milk The celoco Milk Bar Loco
yeah and they were drinking the [__]
breast milk out of the mannequin
dispensers yeah yeah something like that
the little lever but yeah it's like the
milk was coming out of the day
[Laughter]
yeah what was milk with like synthetic
drugs yeah in them that is what it was
but yeah watch A Clockwork Orange if you
haven't seen it by the way that's one of
my favorite movies of all time book's
good too but the book's a little harder
to get through because it's all slang
but you can get through it if you try
um
it is but
they're both good yeah they're they're
well they're similar but I mean it's a
pretty faithful adaptation except for
the end yeah but honestly I I like
Kubrick's ending better or at least like
the choice that he didn't
um adapt the last chapter where Alex
like quote unquote redeems himself or
like grows out of it you know what I
mean because I kind of liked the way
they ended it the movie
um all right so I guess we're gonna wrap
it up because we've been on for like an
hour and a half and I gotta
it's been such a long day you guys it
normally takes me like almost an hour to
get home from work
today it took me two hours there was a
[__] accident on you know where it
was it was on I know you don't usually
go this way but there's a drawbridge
it's old they're building a new overpass
but the overpass isn't done yet like
right next to it so there's a drawbridge
right on the border between Volusia
County where I work in Lake County where
we live
so it's a two-lane drawbridge
some hick in a pickup truck hit another
Hank in a pickup truck on the drawbridge
so it's two lanes
so there's no way around like you can't
get around there's just water
so that so everybody was stopped this
way and everybody was stopped that way
and then like they had the cops out
there while they were cleaning all the
[__] up that they didn't look like they
got hurt but the cars were all [__] up
because when I passed them but so we I
was sitting there
I don't remember how long I was sitting
there most of the time it was just you
were just sitting
I just put the car in park and [__]
sat there like I left the air on and
[__] but so yeah it took me two [__]
hours to get home I didn't get home till
6 30. man I was so [__] mad
but um
and that and while I was sitting there I
was thinking well I guess I made the
right decision like quitting my [__]
job so I don't have to do this every
[__] day
you know because that's actually not the
first time that's happened like a wreck
on that road because it's just like a
two-lane kind of Rural Road so if
somebody wipes out on that road they
have to close it and there's not really
any way around so you just have to sit
there and wait
so yeah that really sucked a lot so I
was a little cranky when I got home a
little cranky
um but yeah I'd say I was waiting on you
you did yeah that sandwich was really
good by the way yeah thanks I was just I
was just glad that it was like a cold
sandwich and it wasn't like just sitting
there like Getting Legs like hot food
getting cold like because I'm sitting
there going God I'm so hungry and I'm
like sitting there in the car and it's
like I had to pee and it's like I was
thirsty because I drank all my water and
I was just kind of like oh my God I was
so upset but uh yeah hopefully I only
have to work at that place for four more
days so hopefully nothing
bad happens I'm keeping my fingers
crossed but yeah so um I think what okay
so the next show is gonna be Wednesday
night
Wednesday night is the main show and the
topic that won I've been wanting to do
this one for a while so finally at one
in the polls we are going to be talking
about the mystery of the Man in the Iron
Mask
so that should be
fun
um I just read an article
that just came out like fairly recently
where they think they figured out who it
was but like obviously they're not
entirely sure because it was a long time
ago but they found some like new papers
or something like that where they think
that they've established his identity
but we'll talk about that on Wednesday
night show so that should be fun like
kind of a historical mystery type of
show
um so yeah thanks thanks everybody for
dropping by this evening and hanging out
with us talking about this underrated
rucker-hour movie which like I said if
you have Amazon Prime you should go
watch it because it's a lot of fun
so yeah come by on Wednesday night we're
going to talk about Iron Mask hopefully
you guys can join us for that and we'll
see you guys on Wednesday night good
night